thor pour avis cher bruno merci madame
la présidente monsieur juste pour
évidemment en deux trois minutes vous
faire un petit retour sur la journée
d'hier où les membres de notre
commission pu conduire 8 audition donc
vous donner en trois parties un petit
peu ce qui a été essentiellement entendu
et sur lesquels nos collègues sont
beaucoup intervenu est d'abord de quoi
parle-t-on en ce qui concerne le sujet
bien précis
on est bien sûr des récoltes avant
floraison et et s'éteint et inclusif
transformation industrielle femme est
soumis à une transformation industrielle
dans le cadre de l' usage de leurs pages
de ces semences donc ça c'était le cadre
des échanges
ensuite il ya eu évidemment la grotte
une grosse partie sur le point sur la
recherche les moyens alloués
les alternatives le calendrier
éventuelles est ce que il faut trois ans
quatre ans cinq ans pour que la
recherche apportent des solutions c'est
forcément un sujet qui qui nous
préoccupe
on a bien compris que les paramètres
pucerons paramètres climat et et des
jeux
évidemment je vous attendais écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention de sa jeunesse que
je crois que cette partie scientifique
elle est essentielle impact mais
effectivement moyens de recherche parce
que des alternatives
aujourd'hui on a bien vu il ya peu et
puis troisième partie de ces huit
audition est essentielle a aussi un
autre sens et ça fait le lien et je suis
très heureux que ce rapport soit vue par
les deux commissions essentielles sur la
situation de la filière économique à
laquelle évidemment on doit une grande
attention
on a bien entendu que les questions
d'europe avaient une incidence et leur
demande transfert de l'activité
économique liée à ce qui se passe c'est
notre pays
voilà madame la présidente en deux trois
minutes
la synthèse des huit auditions et des
trois partis qui sont essentiellement
remontée de ses huit auditions d'hier